I mean sure
we need a little bit of everything in the world.
I am an optimist.
So we can tell the pessimists
the same thing,
"Don't you want some optimism
in the world?"
I believe in balance in the world and
where I get uncomfortable
and I think where life gets uncomfortable
is when we face imbalance.
When there's too much pessimism
in the world
I think it brings us all down.
And the way to defeat pessimism
is with optimism.
But at the same time
if all you have is optimists
then I think we're all gonna be
living in a cloud and
then we become blind as well.
So I think balance is key.
I do my job -
I'm one of the optimists in the world.
I frustrate pessimists
and we need pessimists in the world
and I frustrate them.
But yeah,
we need we need balance.
Long-term needs short-term,
short-term needs long-term,
it's all the same thing.
So I would rather have a slight
imbalance towards optimism.
I would rather have a slight imbalance towards
long-term over short-term.
I would rather have a slight imbalance of
people over profit.
I don't think there's such thing as
perfect balance
there's no such thing as 50/50.
At some point we're gonna face decisions
where something has to give.
You can't have two things be equal all the time.
And so I do believe in biases.
So even though
yes we need pessimists
we need slightly more optimists.
Even though
yes we need short-term thinkers
we need slightly more long-term thinkers.
Even though yes we need finite thinking
we need slightly more infinite thinking.
and that kind of thing.
I think
I'll take an imbalance towards the positive
any day.